[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money
i am rachel cruz best-selling author
ramsey personality and host of the
rachel cruz show hosting today alongside
i like to always say real life friends
that's my official title when we're all
together uh christy wright best-selling
author host of the christy wright show
uh chrissy it's good to be back with you
yeah this is so fun it's uh it was a big
week last week for business boutique and
now back in the back in the weekend i
know how did it go you guys had an event
here in nashville yep and live stream
thousands of women and uh it's just
amazing how every year we change up the
speakers change up the content and every
year it raises the bar it's so fun and
so exhausting and awesome
how was bianca and jasmine because i
know them personally and they are
they're amazing they're so fun do you
know that that was the first time
they've ever spoken together because
they're twins they're 20 that do not
know them but yeah bianca oltof is a
bible teacher and pastor jasmine starr
is a social media expert both of them
are very branded in their individual
spaces they are identical twins and even
though they are identical twins most
people don't know that they're twins
because they're so branded in their
space and they have different laughs
last names so in all the promotion for
this event we did not share that they
were twins and so thursday night bianca
spoke and just brought a great word she
was so powerful and then friday morning
jasmine starr spoke and then we did this
fun reveal and did a panel with both of
them talking about how you find
your unique calling when you are
constantly compared to someone else
great yes it's really
that's so great
all right so we are taking your calls
live at triple eight eight two five five
two two five so give us a call we're
talking money we're talking
business we're talking life we're
talking balance we're talking parenting
anything you want to chat about america
uh christy and i are here because they
they give this to us which is just
absolutely crazy
just keep letting us host together
absolutely crazy okay um before we dive
into the calls i do want to ask because
last time we were on together we were
talking about your planner yep and
different fun things launching how has
that been yeah it's so great so the
planner is awesome i actually had
someone um asking about it last week for
for people that don't know our 2022 goal
planner is out and this is the fourth
year that i've done this planner but
what makes this planner different than
other calendars which are great is um
it's filled with content and worksheets
and journal questions for reflection and
a month in review so there's a lot of
personal growth
tools and content woven into the
calendar and oh by the way that informs
your calendar your to-do list so
um it's one of those things that we try
to pull together all the best
pieces of things we teach we teach you
to read books to grow as a person we
teach you to you know do bible studies
to grow in your faith to journal to
write your goals on paper this is all of
that it is your yeah it's your goal
tools it's all that together so um yeah
it's been fun and people get so excited
because it's really beautiful i mean
it's a piece of it it is it is oh it's
gorgeous it's absolutely gorgeous yeah
so i feel like that's one of the fun
things that we get to do is create these
tools
around
what i think individually we're
passionate about but to help people
because it's like yeah we can talk all
day on shows like this or our own
podcasts
but to be able to live in day in and day
out as you're living life whether you
have a planner next to you helping you
with
kids schedules and your schedule and
appointments and all of it um which just
remind me by the way i have a planner on
my phone like i do it digitally anyways
i didn't take off an appointment so i
took two of my kids to the dentist today
and we didn't have a dentist appointment
i had like not taken off so i actually
probably need your planner
honestly uh not digital because my
digital planners
are not working
um but yeah but one of the things i'm so
excited about the rachel cruz
wallets has been out for a few years now
we have uh just different
different colors different variations of
it but
uh it it's all based around the cash
envelope system because that is
something that we talk about here
those of you that are new to the show
and our money principles one of the
biggest
ways to stay within your budget and
honestly just control your spending and
know what's going on is to use cash and
i know that's kind of now even since
covet and all of that it's kind of like
a it feels like a dying art in the world
today and so i do tell people like it
doesn't have to be for every category
but if you especially people just
starting out budgeting when you are just
at the forefront of hey i'm for the
first time actually saying i have x
amount for groceries this month that's
the first time you've ever done that
yeah you know to have anything visual to
help you day in and day out and cash
really does that i mean it can be
inconvenient at times
but if you have a couple of categories
in your budget to really
help and say hey i'm going to just cash
these out and use it and so the the
wallets that i created helps with that
so
we partnered with join who's an
incredible organization out in india
and they rescue people from
just just trauma devastating life
stories and really take them and give
them a trade show them a skill and put
them to work so they're able to earn
money so it's a beautiful redeeming
business that join is i mean they just
do an incredible job in india um and and
i'll say this too for people that have
bought the wallets um
the owner i was talking to her a few
weeks ago and she just said and thanked
us so much
for partnering with them because even
during coven you know india was hit so
drastically hard during that time and
where everything shut down they were
still able to employ people and still
keep people in business which i think is
just a beautiful amazing
element to all of this which i just love
but um but the wallet we released a new
color this week and so it's called
classic brown i love it classic brown uh
but for the fall season so if you have
not
checked that out make sure to do that
you can do that over at
ramseysolutions.com what are the colors
remind me what the colors are that you
have available now i know this is
getting added but what are the other
ones yeah so we have a camel so we have
like a
uh i don't know how it's a lighter brown
i guess you could say yeah and then
black and then we had a metallic blush
for a short period of time and it sold
out within like i think it was 15 days
they're all gone because it was
beautiful too so popular yes yeah but
but yeah but i just i do i love um these
tools whether it's a whether it's a book
that we have you guys or a planner or
this wallet whatever it is to integrate
into your life and help you because you
find that do you have things in your
life that just it help you stay on track
with things that you want cause goal
setting and knowing where you're going
intentionality is so important to
winning not just in money yes but in so
many aspects well it's one of the things
that we teach here but we also live out
we want to help you live the principle
so anything that we create from ramsey
solutions from any of our personalities
is going to be a tool that helps you
work the plan we don't just create stuff
just to create it it is specifically to
help you get those results and so that's
what i love about it because there's
such a purpose and depth to any product
it's not just a product it's not just
cute and it is beautiful but it actually
helps you work the plan and so i love
the the purpose behind it yep absolutely
absolutely all right well christy and i
are again taking your calls here on the
ramsay show triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're about to head
into a break soon christy but um what
else do you have going on that's that's
exciting so one of the things that's
really fun with the end of the year and
we've talked about this with goal
setting but i think people in this year
with the pant well with the pandemic
last year but even this year people are
just starting to rethink their lives
they're rethinking where they work jobs
yeah that's what it's so fun to think
about ken coleman's new book coming out
in just a few weeks from paycheck to
purpose whether it's a career change
setting new goals finally getting their
money under control
people are rethinking and i think you're
going to see a lot of people make some
positive changes because of that new
awareness yep absolutely absolutely so
great well again aaa 825-5225 christina
are here to answer your questions we'll
be back
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching to pure talk just
go to puretalk.com and enter the promo
code ramsey to save 50 off your first
month pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america i am rachel cruz
here with christy wright taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five all right we're going
to jason in chattanooga hey jason
welcome to the show
how are you guys today doing great
great thanks for taking my call i have a
two-part question for you guys
the first part of the question would be
my wife was terminated from an employer
after 17 years with the company due to
the vaccine mandate
and
we are navigating through this new
chapter in life
and i i really just want to know
what is a way that i can support her
through this let me give you a little
bit of background she's been in
corporate for 17 years and she's going
to transition to go into small business
with me so i know that's completely
different from what she is used to
so i know there's a morning process i
see her going through that now and
and
yeah i thought christy you might could
help me with that part of it
yeah well i love how you first
acknowledge that there's a mourning
process because um it is it's different
and and there's a lot more going on at
her um leaving this job of 17 years than
just losing the paycheck or using the
losing the day-to-day responsibilities
because there's there's this feeling of
was i just a unit of production was that
just a you know is that is that how
after 17 years i'm going to be treated
and so um yeah there's there's the
there's a lot of feelings attached to
this transition but also moving into the
small business type of role is just
going to be a different day-to-day
different responsibilities different
energy tell me a little bit more about
what you do and what she's going to be
doing
yeah so i work at a insurance agency
a property and casualty insurance agency
here in town
and the timing as far as me needing help
to take it to the next level is really
it's really good timing from that
standpoint so i don't think any of this
happened
um
you know just accidentally right i
really don't i think the lord was
completely orchestrating all this that
doesn't take away the morning process
and all those things that go with that
but definitely um
it's good timing from that standpoint
okay well here's what i would do this is
a very simple practice and so many
people don't do it okay so so don't
underestimate it because it's simple
i would sit down with your wife and when
y'all are ready to talk about her role
in the business and that type of thing i
would have i would ask her say i want
you to define what success looks like in
this role for you
what are your what tasks are you
passionate about what are you good at
what does a typical day look like what
gets you energized what do you love
doing and let's just and with in light
of what you're doing right like in the
context of what she would be doing for
you write out that list and then you
separately
write out a list of what success looks
like for you what is the help that you
need what are the problems you need
solved what are the gaps that you need
filled and see where this overlap falls
between what she wants to do and what
you need now likely there's going to be
some things that you need that she
doesn't want to do and you can figure
out what to do with those does she do
them anyway because we all have things
we don't want to do
sure or do you find someone else to do
that part of it but i think the biggest
factor to set you guys up for success is
simply defining success from the get-go
success in her mind and success in your
mind and making sure that there's a
connection point between those it may
not be 100 overlap maybe it's 80 percent
overlap and you figure out what to do
with the other 20 percent but so often
um you have an idea in your head and she
has an idea in her head and you all both
start running and those are not the same
idea and that leads to conflict
miscommunication and just overall
frustration and more mistakes made so i
would just have her write out what this
looks like have you write out what it
looks like define success and then just
have some conversations around that i
think that's going to set you up uh from
a really strong standpoint out of the
gate yeah that's good jason is is the
things that she was doing in her
previous job
going to be similar to kind of what
she's well not really she's
she was a senior manager at a company um
very high up and so i i knew from the
beginning
that her identity finding an identity
that
she's happy with is going to be
difficult because this is so much
different than a large company
so
i've already given her some things to do
taking some i.t stuff and running with
it and
she
has really enjoyed that she's already
played with that some so
i think just finding the identity is
going to be a big deal
this may be a real basic question but
she want to do this
i know you need it but does she want to
do this for you
i think she does i just think yeah i
think she would tell you that she does
well i think i mean
that's that's huge but and i just heard
you say she went from a senior manager
role that she very much found a part of
her identity in which is fine
to being more of a support role for you
that's a shift not in not just in tasks
but in
the role that you play and so i think
that if you're sensitive to that that
will be huge especially in this
transition process but if she wants to
do it then she'll she'll want to figure
out how to make that
make that modification how how old is
she jason
she's 44. 44. okay okay yeah so she
still has some years we've been married
20 years and
we've never dealt with anything like
this thankfully applying their
principles you guys teach and mr ramsey
teaches we're we're in good shape um
the second thing i wanted to add real
quick if i can
we have a 401k
that we have
invested specifically the way dave has
said his
gross stock mutual funds long track
record we've done that for years and
it's it's done very very well what do we
do with this thing now should we sit on
it for a couple of months and let the
smoke settle what do you guys recommend
the first thing i would say is to
contact one of our smartvestor pros
because they'll be able to tactically
help you walk through tangibly all of
these changes but
traditionally i would say when you leave
a company that you would want to roll
your 401k into just a traditional ira
if you guys can pay the taxes on it you
could even do a roth ira at that point
um but again a smart investor pro can
definitely walk through all those
details yep and that thanks jason
you know he brings up an interesting
point and um
i guess i've thought about this but not
just in depth is is that um
shift of people that are leaving their
jobs
changing careers for whatever reason it
could be anything
but how much we do find and value
especially if you love your work and
your job right um
who you are in it right and then there's
that morning
you know that takes place especially if
it's a if it's a decision that wasn't
your own or you felt backed in a corner
that you had to leave um that is really
real for a lot of people out there that
are in transition one i think there we
can swing to these extremes of we only
find our identity in our work and that's
a dangerous place to be because your
work can change just like even finding
your identity in relate in terms of
relationships if those relationships
change we we there's a danger in our
only source of identity being followed
there uh falling there but
then we can swing to the other extreme
of saying well um i don't find my
identity in anything that i do it's like
my identity is in christ and it's just
that simple and that sounds nice but
there's a very healthy
normal level of identifying with the
work that you do every day if you spend
40 plus hours a week of doing anything
you're going to find at least a part of
your identity there yeah and and i think
as long as you hold it with open hands
and understand this is something that i
do it's not who i am yes but because i
do it so much i do identify with that i
do pride myself on the work that i do or
you know you've been with this company
17 years like that that's a big part of
who you are anytime you invest a lot of
time in something a job a relationship
anything it does become a part of you
and when that changes if it does there
is a little bit of mourning and um and
so i think we have to figure out what
that healthy balance in the middle looks
like of yes we're going to find a little
bit of our identity there like i
identify as i'm a runner you know yeah
yeah it's like it's like i don't you
identify as that i do i do not and you
don't and you don't really mourn the
loss of that no i don't
i quit marathon training two weeks in i
was like heck no this is stupid but this
is a healthy amount yeah there's a
healthy amount of holding with open
hands and going yeah this is part of who
i am in a healthy normal way yes and at
the same time it's not only who i am and
so i think we need to just acknowledge
that because when you're going through a
change or losing a part of yourself yeah
give yourself some grace in that
transition in that morning because that
was a big piece of who you were and it's
okay if that changes you know and i
think that there's not you know there
shouldn't be shame or embarrassment
either to have those feelings and i love
that even jason pointed that out about
his wife because i think
sometimes we can be in the mindset of
like just you know pull your boots up
and just just charge you know it's like
no there's a big part of your life that
is shifting and changing and if that
makes that's hard and sad then let it be
you know for a little bit so that's
great awesome
well christy and i again uh are happy to
be here answering your questions you
also triple eight eight two five five
two two five and we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
if you aren't strapped with student loan
payments you probably know someone who
is there are millions of people that are
literally putting their lives on hold
they can't buy a house or have kids
because they're just stuck and they're
waiting and waiting and the worst part
is they're waiting for the government
to save them with student loan
forgiveness and it's just it's a joke
uh our team has produced a new
documentary you guys and it's incredible
it's called borrowed future and it is
out now it uncovers the dark side of the
student loan industry and exposes how
the system is built to work against you
and so you'll see dave ramsey weigh in
on the epic failure otherwise known as
the student loan program and has
interviews with some of the industry
insiders and thought leaders like seth
godin seth from and dr john deloney
and we're coming at this hard ramsey
solutions really we're taking a big
swing at the student loan problem with
the goal to lock arms with parents and
students around the country with the
truth that you do not
have to take out loans to get a college
degree you can
graduate debt free and avoid the
predatory student loan industry so
borrowed future is available now you can
watch it on apple tv amazon prime google
play or go to borrowed future.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promo codes they run every
month you'll save even more use promo
code ramsay to get the best deal rules
and restrictions apply
today's question comes from daisy in
tennessee i work full time and also have
a side business that i've worked hard to
build it's grown to the point where it's
becoming hard to manage my time and i've
not done a good job of serving my
customers which really bothers me i've
been praying about working on my
business full time and leaving my
current job
how do i overcome the fear of leaving a
great job and benefits
so i love this question because it's
really common and anyone listening right
now that has a side business maybe you
have a side hustle maybe you started it
just to work on your debt snowball
faster and as you're doing it you're
thinking wow i really love this it gives
me joy
i'm passionate about it what if i did
this full time what if i could quit my
full-time job well the thing that we
tell people all the time is we don't
want you to walk out on your study
paycheck tomorrow i don't want you to
have this jerry maguire moment where you
grab the goldfish and say who's with me
that's fun in the movies and not fun in
real life
nothing will
make your dream a burden like having um
the money being the driver driving force
where you the money's not there so
here's what i want you to do for daisy
or anyone
daisy one of the things that you said in
your question is that you've grown it to
the point where you're spending a lot of
time on it but you didn't mention how
much money you're making in it and i'm
not as interested how much time you
spent on it as i am how much money
you're making as long as that time
converts to two dollars you're bringing
in and so what we tell people to do is
you need to build up your side business
so much from a financial standpoint the
revenue the personal income standpoint
that it can support you now let's say
for example that daisy is working a
full-time job and she makes 60 000 a
year
and her side business she's built it up
to 30 000. well it's not the equivalent
of her full-time job but if she can make
some cuts in her budget and her expenses
and live on 30 then daisy you can quit
tomorrow because the money is there to
support you and the more that you work
on your business the more you could get
that that personal income up even to be
60 000 or more but the money has to be
there so the way that the analogy dave
ramsey uses is you want to pull the boat
close enough to the top dock that when
you step in the boat it's you don't fall
in the water and so the idea is like how
do i make the leap how do i make the
leap to full time
i don't want you to make a leap i want
you to make a step when you take steps
you don't fall as much it doesn't hurt
as much and so build up that business
enough daisy where that income
from the business you can live on it and
then when the money is there then then
yeah you'll still feel a little scared
because it's new and different but you
at least have proof hey i have the
income to support me i'm gonna be okay
and you know rachel we get calls like
this on the ramsay show i've noticed
there's a pattern where sometimes people
call in
and they're like i'm scared to
pay off my last debt even though i have
all the money in savings or i'm scared
to
spend this money on this car even though
i have the money yeah sometimes there's
an irrational fear just because it feels
risky or new or different
the numbers don't lie if the numbers are
there from a savings account standpoint
from in your case daisy from your
business standpoint you know that even
though it's scary because it's different
the money is there to support you and
that's why we teach what we teach so
that the money can support you yeah the
numbers don't have feelings yeah they
talk they will show you and tell you and
sometimes we let that fear and those
emotions get in the way yeah and if the
money's not there you're not ready yeah
absolutely get the money up yeah all
right we're gonna go to mike in
lexington kentucky hey mike welcome to
the show
hey can you all hear me yeah yes what's
going on hey
so a question my fiance and i uh going
to be getting married we both currently
own our house you know we each own a
house
but neither neither of us are really set
on moving into one another we see
ourselves you know buying a new house
where we start our family and that kind
of stuff
so my question to you all is is it smart
for us to keep one of our houses as an
investment property we both are
debt-free besides our mortgages
and sell one house
to help you know put a down payment on
the next one
or is it dumb to have two mortgages
neither of our homes are paid off yet we
both again are debt-free and
you know have good income stuff like
that yeah that's great great question
and i'll tell you mike from
always sitting in the seat that i'm in
when i hear real estate questions i like
have my husband and my dad in my head
because they
love real estate they love passive
income this is like their bread and
butter they love it so my answer i'm
telling you comes from
someone who is in a family and married
to someone who loves real estate but
when it comes to investment properties
um and expanding past just that fifteen
percent of your income into retirement
on baby step four we really want you to
be in baby step seven uh when you go to
look at rental properties
and and i know that's not the answer you
wanted because you're like we have
stable income we're good i know you
wanted me to just be like yes you can
keep one and i and i understand
even mathematically you could look and
say yeah i mean it should work with the
math but what you have to remember is
that life happens and the two mortgages
and if you don't have a tenant in the
house or if something breaks i mean it's
just this level of risk at this point
and so you guys uh you're in an amazing
position i mean you guys don't have
consumer debt uh you both own homes so
even selling those in this market today
if that's what you're choosing to do
um
to go buy something else you should have
great equity so but my question would be
why why not just live in one of them and
sell the other
well we've thought about that um
certainly but we you know both of our
houses are are small and if if and when
the time comes for kids and
dogs and things like that are you know
we have less less than a thousand square
foot in our house okay um so we're just
thinking
you know more
yeah down the road when that comes kind
of deal absolutely and i think that
that's that's wise but i would i would
encourage you guys at this point
especially since you're going to be
newly married to maybe just say hey for
a year we're going to just live in one
of our homes and just kind of let the
death settle get marriage worked out
figure you know get all this kind of in
a in a more you know quote unquote
stable position because of a big life
change like marriage and then maybe it's
i don't know fall of 2022 and you say
okay we're ready for a bigger place
uh and then you choose to make that leap
um to something brand new versus just
living in one of yours just as an idea
because you guys aren't you don't have
to have something bigger right this
second i mean if you were expecting or
something like that i could see that um
but even just being in one house just
for a little bit
uh i don't i don't think is a bad plan
at all well and one of the things that
that will give you um mike is it will
just give you perspective of that first
year of marriage because when you get
married i remember the first year of
marriage with matt we learned so much
about each other and how we lived and
house responsible like there's a big
learning curve of merging your life with
someone else and what's so interesting
is in a year you guys may know more
about what you want what neighborhood
you want to be in what you want in a
house and once you've lived together to
talk about some of that stuff you could
you could guess now but you'll really
know after a year of living together so
it definitely can't hurt um and the
other thing that i just would remind you
um mike is a lot of times we'll have
this question of should i do this and
it's just because you're sort of
inheriting a situation if you would not
set out to go buy a rental property to
become a landlord your first year of
marriage then you're not going to keep
that situation in which puts you in that
situation sometimes we just want to keep
it because we're already there well if
you wouldn't go do that today then it's
not the right thing yep so i'd live in
one of the homes sell the other one and
then here in about nine nine to 12
months look to sell that and
move up in house if you guys want
congratulations mike too marriage is
awesome we're excited for it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america this is rachel cruz
and rams personality and best-selling
author christy wright
you can give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five and we
are answering your questions
all right up next is john in grand
rapids michigan hey john welcome to the
show
hey good afternoon ladies how are you
doing great how can we help
hey got a question for you um
i was planning on going on a vacation
this weekend
and
just had an emergency arise today that's
going to probably take half of our
emergency fund
and we're thankful we have that but i
don't know if i should cancel this
vacation and
you know
go back to stockpiling money to rebuild
our emergency fund or worry about that
when i get back
great question was your emergency fund
more on the six month end of the
spectrum or more like the three month
before the emergency uh
it was closer to three it was probably
three to four three to four so it cuts
it down to what probably a month and a
half of savings yeah about about that we
don't know for sure um
i would i made a really bad
judgment call and drove my tractor over
top my septic tank and fell through wow
so we have to get a new septic tank put
in gosh
tell me a little bit because i mean it's
this weekend it's in like 48 hours right
yeah i'll be leaving early early
saturday morning okay what what it is it
entails all the family i'm just
nope it's just me i'm going by myself i
plan to trip up to the upper peninsula
michigan just to go do some photography
for four or five days
gotcha um it's fairly cheap you know
three on the low end 500 on the high end
is how much i'd spend on the whole trip
with gas and everything so
yeah and how much do you make a year
john
uh household incomes about 85. 85.
you know i have i always have big dave
in my head sitting there i was like you
got two spenders giving you advice right
now listen john honestly i mean again if
you were going to be spending 10 grand
going somewhere super fancy and all of
this i would probably
let's pause
but three to five hundred dollars with
your income
everything i mean i think you're fine
going i mean i would i would focus in on
when you get back yeah bumping that back
up um but to build up that emergency
fund you could you you can do that in
three or four months focusing all your
efforts
um
and now now it i will say this though
john it is a vaca it's not a i always
feel the pressure that if it's a
vacation that you know you can't cancel
because of a hotel policy if there's
family if other people are involved in
the plans that that's a harder one to
just flat out cancel this one it's just
you so if you didn't want to press pause
and go in two months you could do that
and probably be on the safe side but
because it's not a huge dollar amount
and you still have around a month and a
half two-month buffer there um
i'm okay with it and we tell people once
you're once you're debt-free like you
know yes you want to build that
emergency fund fast but that's when
you're able to kind of celebrate and
enjoy life um a little bit more yeah i
think for me the dollar amount is what
is the determining factor like
i don't know what dave would say if he
were here if he would hear he might be
like no don't go
but dave's done here john dave's not
here me and rachel are your friendly
spenders just giving you advice no i
mean seriously it's it's
it's negligible in the grand scheme of
the emergency funds you already have and
the income that you make and it's in two
days go take some pictures enjoy your
photography i don't think it's a big
deal if you want to cancel it you can
there it's it's not a big deal either
way but i think if you want to go you
can start building that emergency fund
right back up when you get back the fact
that you're even calling shows that
you're cognizant you're you're a saver
you're doing great yeah uh but yeah i
don't think it's a big deal if you go
and consult your wife and if she's
feeling uncomfortable then i would i
would add that in there too but
i think i think you're
i think you're good again again only
because
you have still some emergency fund it's
not a huge dollar amount and your income
is 85 000 a year yeah
it's gonna i think you're gonna be
you're gonna be okay it's not gonna make
her your this vacation is not gonna make
or break your emergency fund that's
right or your ability to build it back
up that's right all right up next is t
shaw in wichita kansas hey welcome to
the show
how are you ladies great what's going on
good
uh well i'm
my husband and i are kind of
in the middle of trying to make some
decisions as far as
what it is we want to do
um with our lives as far as if we move
and
potential career changes if we decide
that we want to go that route
and really my question is
you know how do you go about discussing
those decisions
you know full-time parents full-time
jobs and then you get home you're
exhausted and you're just kind of
overwhelmed with everything coming at
you in life because
i feel like we've got it coming at all
ends um
yeah well tell tell us a little bit more
about your situation what do you both
currently do for work and what are your
kids ages and how many kids give us a
little bit of a picture of what we're
talking about here
okay so um i'm a financial spreads
analyst for bank and my husband is a
heavy equipment operator and foreman for
a construction company
um so both very solid you know essential
jobs
when it comes to that
and
our children
are the oldest is three years and the
youngest is just 10 months
you know so they're they're very active
um you know going to daycare full-time
of course i want to be a stay-at-home
mom i never thought i would say that
um you know and there's just everything
going on has made me just kind of want
to
go home and squeeze my kids and just not
even worry about work the next morning
um
you know there's been a lot going on in
the community
you know that just
makes you feel like life is just way too
short to be focused on the career yeah
um so t-shirt so is your is your goal
here to
shift out of working to be that
stay-at-home mom
um i would like to yeah i would really
like to do that um
i don't know if that's possible yeah
have you guys are you guys on
are you guys on a budget baby step two
you're on baby step two yeah we're yeah
we're on baby step two we have about 85
000 in debt and we bring
depending on my husband's job
annually both of us household income is
about 80 to 90 000 a year 80 to 90
combined
yes combined okay
um well this is i mean it's really a
value system
kind of conversation i mean obviously
the math when you're looking just
strictly at the money on the piece you
know the seat that i sit in um to get
you guys out of debt the fastest
and to
get yourself in a stable position um i
mean you guys you know if you really
buckle down you could be you could be
out of debt in two and a half years if
you really just cut everything
or
you could just map it out and say okay
if we
if i do quit and i stay home and this is
cut by how much how much do you
contribute to the 80 to 90 000
half of it okay so it goes down to 40 45
000
um and what does that look like and so
um for some people it's worth it some
people it's like yeah we will
i'll figure out a way if i can make
money from home
because my number one desire is to be
with my kids right now and that's all i
want some people say you know what i'm
going to sacrifice
that longing for just
48 more months
sorry 24 more months and do what i can
to to get this debt out of the way um
but again i think it is a it's a it's a
values conversation between you and your
husband and what and what you what you
decide but this
this debt is holding you back and that's
one of the reasons we
we talk so strongly about this whether
it's student loans or car loans it's
like this
this this culture you know you're you're
working to pay bills and that sucks you
know that that is that's the miserable
part of all of this
uh t-shirt you said you're a financial
analyst
yes okay i i think that you can look for
something else
i i think that you can look for
something else and work from home there
are a bazillion work from home jobs you
can be making more than you're making
right now with your skill set you also
could start a business if you wanted to
if you'll stay on the line i'll have
kelly send you a copy of my book
business boutique because while that's a
plan to start your business it also
might just give you your idea for what
your business is but i think you don't
want to walk out tomorrow like we said
but i do think you can start to look at
something that could still get you out
of debt but help you be home a little
bit more absolutely all right i want to
thank our producer ben hill and
associate producer kelly daniel
and you chrissy wright for co-hosting
the show with me so fun and this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i am best-selling author ramsey
personality rachel cruz hosting today
with my good friend best-selling author
and host of the christy wright show
christy wright this is so fun i love
this good to be back with you
we are hitting the phones this hour you
guys were talking about everything from
yeah everything that involves your life
whether it's your money it's your work
it's your kids it's your schedule it's
your balance anything all of it uh we
are here to hang out and and talk about
it which is just so fun i love
this show because i just love diving
into people's lives for about five four
to five minutes depending how long we
have with them um because everyone has a
story yeah everyone has things going on
in their life and christy and i are
sitting here in the studio in in
nashville tennessee just here wanting to
help direct and guide you on everything
that um
everything we know i don't know
though
this is so uh known as a money show you
know it's been a money show for over 30
years and people often think they're
calling in with a money question and
it's rarely a money question sometimes
it is sometimes it's as simple as yeah
we're going to move this investment here
or we need to save this amount of money
sometimes it is
a lot of times it's a deeper
conversation and we had some of that in
the last hour um you guys call in you
know we'll have here here's the
conversation my spouse and i can't agree
on this that or the other and it's
really a marriage question it's a it's a
communication question it's a
relationship question it's a boundaries
question and so we love to help you look
at this through a different lens and
peel away the layers of the issue below
the issue and talk about it there and oh
by the way of course that does have an
effect in your money decisions and in
your bank account but um yeah that's the
reason we like to let you guys know
we're not just talking about money if
you have a question about something else
we're here for you but often the money
questions are actually uh a different
type of question uh camped in that so
we're here to help you absolutely so
again triple eight eight two five five
two two five okay we have ruth in
seattle up next hey ruth welcome to the
show
hey you two are amazing
thanks
okay i'm pretty sure this is a money
question all right
my question has to do with how exactly
to calculate the emergency fund um i
mean i'm in baby step three
and um we'll probably make about 45
k this year between
instacart shopper and
ubereats
and
i'm trying to figure out
does the stream of well i'm kind of on
the fence about three or six months but
when it comes down to the numbers
is it
three let's go let's go with the three
months just for example um is it three
months of everything including
lifestyles if any any and all bills that
you've got or
do or should i chisel down to say the
other day i kind of
pretended i
you know pretend you have a car you had
a car accident and just to figure out
what you would be paying for it and what
you would cancel out yeah for three
months type thing how would you which
one would you go with yeah that's a
great question ruth um
you know you can go about this
kind of both ways honestly i talk to
some people and they want the three
three-month emergency fund where their
life doesn't change that if they lose a
job or a spouse loses a job or something
happens that they don't have to shift
their lifestyle much that they have
three months that they can live
consistently on uh as is now other
people it is more of the bare bones it's
more like hey to not be late on bills
electricity cell phone it's more of
those four walls making sure we're
eating where we we get the mortgage paid
or the rent paid uh it's really the bare
bones and calculating that and you're so
in that instance you're cutting out
things like out to eat you're cutting
out
shopping if you have a clothing you know
thing that you can you can do without
that for a few months like more of that
bare bones so it's kind of how quickly
you want to get to it and then to decide
okay is it three or six months so so i
would lean on the three-month side you
know if someone is out there and they're
single if they have a pretty steady
income you know a job that's pretty
predictable
you could probably live on a three-month
emergency fund now if you have kids a
lot of dependents if you're married if
you're on commission
uh if you're ju if it's not really a
very stable you know situation like you
said for yours for instance you know
instacart and ubereats is that what
you're saying you do
yeah so for that you know that's a
little bit more volatile in a sense you
know you're not just on a strict salary
so in your case i would probably lean
closer to a six-month mark in that but
whichever one you take and for you
because you're gonna be on that six
month i would almost do a bare bones
budget to say okay if i cut out all the
fluff of my lifestyle and really have to
stick to my bills
um i would have that um as your six
month if i were you ruth are you are you
married do you have kids
no but it's just me okay okay awesome so
um
yeah i mean
i hope yeah you know it's great um so
yeah so if i were you i mean well yeah
now that you're not i mean you could
probably do closer to four months if you
wanted um and again it can be the
bare-bones budget or you could say i
just want to be comfortable
um and have that
that
budget they want to get to the next goal
huh what'd you say well they're all
going to know how fast they want to get
to the next goal basically yeah it does
that but i think that's the reason i
mean the way that i've always looked at
it ruth um and i don't know that
anyone's ever told me this i think i've
just kind of looked at it this way the
reason we give that range is for that
reason we we give a range of three to
six months and i've always looked at it
as if you're going the three month route
it's probably going to be a three month
you're not changing your lifestyle if
you're in the six month route it's
probably six months of bare bones but
the number could be defined either way
it's yes three months if we don't change
anything or it's our sixth month of bare
bones you know if um like in in my case
having three little kids i want a more
full emergency fund for peace of mind
because i have more people i'm
responsible for in your case i mean yeah
like if you're like yeah i feel good on
four months of you know uh middle middle
of the ground you know middle road
whatever i think you're fine i think we
give you that range for some freedom and
flexibility with your comfort level
probably all of our savers and our nerds
are gonna have a six month and all of
our spenders like i'm fine on three
months so uh there's a little bit of
flexibility in there for you to adapt it
for what's right for you yeah that and i
think that is so true that when i first
got married and we were going we were
doing the baby steps we did it and it
was like okay we had the emergency fund
and and i had some money that i brought
in he had a little bit of savings we
were kind of like you know i was like oh
yeah three definitely three months
barebone plenty let's move on let's move
on and then once i had kids we have a
family i went back um i mean it's
probably been five years now or so but i
was like hey let's like really beef up
that emergency fund just so i know so i
know so i know so i know that that's in
there if something happens and that's
the beautiful thing you guys about this
i mean and ruth congrats on being on
baby step three that means that she's
gotten out of debt that's right and now
you're moving on to that and ruth i'm
excited for you to hit that baby step
three because there is this emotional
piece that you get when you're like okay
i don't owe anyone anything
we have money saved so god forbid i i
lose a job something shifts uh another
pandemic like whatever happens
there is that safety net and there is
something to that peace of mind that is
priceless yeah yeah absolutely that's
why it's there it's not just about the
money it's about the peace of mind
absolutely this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
well you guys i have
the perfect gift for you and all the
women on your shopping list for this
holiday season
this gift actually makes budgeting look
beautiful
i have had a best-selling camel color
wallet and black color wallet
of the rachel cruz wallets and we are
out now with a brand new color just in
time for the holidays and it's actually
the most popular color
according to the manufacturer that we
work with and that is classic brown so
this genuine leather classic brown
wallet can literally go with anyone's
style it's timeless which is my favorite
and the best part is that these wallets
go beyond just the beautiful exterior
that you see but it really does it helps
you budget it is handmade authentic
leather so it smells
really wonderful
i'm unboxing one over here and it is so
beautiful it's such quality leather and
like we were talking about earlier this
is the tool that helps you work the plan
with your cash that's right you can see
when your cash is getting low in your in
your specific slot for whatever that
thing is that full-blown envelope system
right here and all the debit card slots
that you need so last christmas
um we saw post after boast of people
saying that this was the perfect gift
they were buying it for all the women in
their life which is so fun so it is
available to order now and we'll ship by
early november so you can get your
rachel cruz wallet and our classic brown
color by texting rc brown to
33789 again that's rc brown
three three seven eight nine even the
box is beautiful like this is like it's
a perfect gift box isn't it great the
presentation is is awesome yeah i
appreciate that and just a reason a
reminder for people um shipping is just
weird right now across the country
everyone is experiencing
unpredictability some delays in shipping
so if you want something from the ramsey
solutions store for christmas get it now
whether it's the wallet or a book or
something else get it now just to make
sure you don't face any of those close
calls in december absolutely all right
we're gonna go to the phones with
christopher in atlanta georgia hey
christopher welcome to the show
hi thank you guys for being here
absolutely how can we help all right i
guess um my question will be um i'm 22
right now uh making about a little bit
over
um 85k
wow um i guess um my question would be
kinda
what um
but
i guess what what exactly um with being
22 some steps that i can take to make
sure that i'm managing my money properly
um with making this type of money um
being this young
yeah it's a great question great
question yeah what do you what do you do
i'm a cloud engineer
great so so awesome
oh man okay 22 making 85 000 do you do
you have any debt
um right now i have um about
about
uh 9k and um in student loan but i still
have about a semester left so um i'm
debating about just go ahead and pay it
off
and i have about
about 40 40k um saved up wow
that's awesome
um well to answer your question yes i
would pay off that student loan i mean
that 9 000 for sure i'd pay that off and
then cash flow that last semester
of school um
which is absolutely incredible
incredible well i'll give you my top
piece of advice and then christy you can
you can chime in
so at 22 i mean you have
so much going for you the fact that
obviously your income is amazing you
really you're gonna be debt free by the
end of today and if it were up to me
that you just write the check and you do
it um but you know i think the biggest
mistake people make christopher that we
see all the time is that they're just
not intentional
and i know it's a really broad piece of
advice but
people really do they float through life
they make great money just like you and
they just spend and go and they look up
at 40 45 and they realize oh gosh you
know i've tacked on some debt here i i
don't really have a lot in retirement
and oh and they feel themselves
realizing well i was not intentional
with this money and so if you really do
kind of buckle down
live on a budget which again
where you're at budget does not mean
that it's going to limit your lifestyle
in fact it's going to give you a lot of
freedom to enjoy your lifestyle and if
you
i'll have you hang on the line when we
get off the call here
because we'll give you a subscription to
ramsey plus because
every dollar plus is our budgeting app
that helps with this and helps you
budget and know exactly where every
dollar is going
um and there and there's something
powerful about that and then from there
being able to walk the baby steps and
again with you you you pretty much are
on baby step four five and six at this
point um meaning that you'll be out of
debt you have a fully funded emergency
fund
and you're gonna be able to start
investing into retirement uh saving up
for a house if you haven't bought a home
and that's something you to do in the
near future
and really i mean you're going to walk
this path so fast christopher um which
is amazing
and to be able to just be extremely
generous as well and that's another
piece of that puzzle i would put in but
all of that to say under the umbrella of
just do things on purpose yeah be
intentional don't just float through
life with your money yeah the only thing
that i would um add christopher just in
consideration of the overall plan that
rachel just laid out for you the one
thing that's um specific to you is your
age and so you are at such a young age
and coming into um a season of life
where a lot of people experience a lot
of transition so i love how much money
you have saved i would just continue to
add to that in addition to you know
paying off the debt like she said and
cash flowing college and um starting
investing and all that just continue to
stockpile cash because
if and when you're ready to buy a house
you've got a down payment if you decide
to get married you've got some money for
a wedding a honeymoon whatever and so
there's a a lot of people experience a
lot of very expensive
life changes between 20 and 30 in a lot
of cases and so you're already on that
track just um maybe go above and beyond
your your three to six months expenses
from a savings standpoint because you
may want to access that money for a
house down payment that type of thing
and you could start now and then gosh
you have that much more to put down when
and if you're ready to do it yeah you're
doing awesome yeah christopher can i ask
you you know what was your upbringing
like did your
parent or parents like
talk to you about this stuff or you just
kind of happen to not have a ton of
student loans but great income or what
kind of what's your story
um it's kind of a little
difficult to explain um kane um from you
know that went ahead and got adopted um
young age and um
got into a couple situation actually um
have kids um have kids very young um and
that's kind of what really really made
me you know started focusing and so on
yeah and
and since then i just know that i i i
want to be ahead in life um for them and
and so on and i guess i'm just wanting
to go
back where i came from and um starting
the orphanage opening something like
that um and i know that i have to work
hard from another age to be able to do
that i guess that that's really was my
upbringing just making sure that i can
get ahead as young as possible and to be
able to to do all the stuff that i have
planned and making sure
all my kids have a good life instead of
them yeah wow absolutely that's amazing
and you are
oh oh absolutely i mean just obviously
calling in and being
aware of the responsibility that you
have because that is one thing
you know you consider we we talk about
money here a lot and money i always say
is a tool to create a life that you love
you want to take control of it but it is
a tool it's not the end i'll be all it's
not the thing that the number one goal
that you know you're working towards is
just it's just cash and money um it is a
tool to
do life with i mean it is a tool to
create a life that you want it's a tool
to be able to help people and so
making any kind of money i mean you know
if you what is it if you have two cars
and
food in your refrigerator you're like in
the top
two percent of the universe or something
right i mean like so there there's just
a level of responsibility that we all
have and that we carry to do this well
to do this well and not let the money
ruin us
uh from an emotional standpoint or a
financial where you go into so much debt
and it's stressful and you know you're
working a job you hate to pay bills all
of that but
but really seeing this is okay this is
this is a responsibility how do i do
this well yeah and it was like you were
just talking about being intentional i
mean you already have been christopher
with having forty thousand dollars in
savings that didn't just appear in your
bank account that's right you have been
intentional and worked really hard to
get there i think just um following
those baby steps and continuing that
you're going to be able to set yourself
up to do those things you just described
for the legacy you want to leave to be
the type of person you want to be to
help the people that you want to help
and i think that's awesome and when you
have a deeper why
that is what fuels you way more than
anything at the surface and you do
christopher you do well done absolutely
and to show that your past does not
dictate your future your past choices
you can make decisions today to change
yeah not just who you are but even your
money habits and what you're doing with
this so so well done christopher very
very awesome
well
this is the ramsey show again we're
taking your calls america aaa 825-5225
[Music]
[Music]
well in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage we have nick and
ashley and you're on the stage for a
reason i know that you guys welcome to
the show thank you where are you guys
from
minden nevada okay nevada great okay so
you guys you're here to do your
debt-free scream
congratulations thank you yeah so how
much debt did you guys pay off
uh thirty six thousand one hundred and
eighty three dollars awesome count and
count the dollars i love that thirty six
thousand and how long did it take you
ten months ten months making what kind
of money
we started at 48 000 and got up to 104.
whoa
what quite a jump there tell us about
that we both switched jobs which was
part of it the first month was just on
her income because i was in between
switching jobs and then with the job i
went to i got in a much better spot and
then she switched jobs as well what do
you guys do i'm a service writer for
hyundai okay and then i work in a dental
office yes awesome amazing okay and how
long have you guys been married three
years three years okay
so what happened 10 months ago that you
said oh this this 36 000 is just we're
feeling it
we originally
did this it was a prerequisite by her
father to go through financial peace
before we got married oh and uh me too
we went through that and we're like oh
we don't have that much debt and then a
couple years into being married we we
switched it up and it was like okay it's
it's time to do this yes well and i
think when he was switching jobs we were
going to go a month where it was just my
income
and we looked at our budget and we were
like we're not going to make it like and
that was a point for us where we're like
we don't have anything in savings we
don't have like any extra money i don't
know how we're gonna get groceries for
like this next month while we're just
waiting on like my income so i think
that was like our low point and we're
like we can do this yeah so what was the
36 000
it was cars credit card and then an old
car loan that we didn't even have the
car anymore anymore so it's just kind of
normal so i mean you are the classic you
kind of just are living paycheck to
paycheck if something happens you're
like oh gosh what do we do we can't we
can't make it
so what was the conversation like then
when you realized okay
we are not going to make it on just my
income i'm we're starting to kind of
freak out we're starting to see the
reality of this debt and the bills
who came to who how did that
conversation happen she came to me i am
110 free spirit here um i have very
expensive tastes and a lot of things and
she was like hey um we i want to get out
of debt i you know i was that one for a
while i was like we'll do it over time
like you know it's fine it'll go away
and then uh it never went away and it
got to the point the month i was
switching jobs i'm like wow i i don't
want this anymore yeah sometimes that
sometimes that freak out that you guys
described is incredibly motivating to
change like you almost need this freak
out moment where you're scared
enough to consider doing something
different and doing something hard i
think it's funny that you said you're
the um you were the resistant one
because i've noticed a consistent
pattern that the resistant spouse is
always the free spirit actually it's
never the nerd that's like i don't know
if we should save money it's like
they're always the one that's on board
the free spirit's like no don't box me
rules it'll just go away i love that say
i love that you said that i was like oh
yeah it'll just go away exactly and you
know she just kept like sliding me
brochures and like conveniently i'd find
her old financial piece back and i'm
like okay
i get it i get it i get it okay so what
did you guys do i mean obviously you
switched jobs so the income helped
tremendously but what else what else did
your did your story look like through
this um i can't believe i'm going to say
this but covet actually helped us with
because you know you don't want to go
out and do anything well
you can't go out and do anything so it
was one of those
that helped uh and i mean you know just
sacrifices all around i mean well and
you picked up pizza delivering too for a
while and he was working six days a week
and that was like our new normal was i
would barely see him and then yeah when
i did see him he was doing pizza runs
and
all that yeah i went up to my boss it
was like my second month i was like hey
i know i'm supposed to work tuesday
through saturday but i'm gonna work
mondays too and he's like
okay
so amazing isn't that crazy i'm like the
two elements of people's money it's your
expenses and when you cut that whether
it's the culture has cut it for you
because of covid and there's nothing to
do and spend money on
and you raise that income how drastic
those those two elements if you can get
those under control how much you can see
that progress oh it's huge so what would
the key be someone listening right now
and they're thinking okay these guys got
out of 36 000 worth of debt
what would you say like the secret to
getting out of debt is
i heavily relied on my nerd i'll 100
admit it but um no i mean just just be a
team about it communication and
everything is huge
so what what did marriage look like for
you guys because i mean this is a big
it's a big struggle for people money and
getting on the same page and i know i
love that you're just so
uh you just raise your hand and say yeah
i'm the free spirit i'm the one that
pushed back against it but what did
those conversations look like at the
beginning
a lot of them were
let's sit down and talk to budget and
i'd say maybe later
and you know eventually it got to i
wanted to talk about the budget but i
mean it was a lot you know there was
there was the tough times i mean you
know we used to go on road trips to go
visit family and we'd just listen to the
show over and over and it was just it
was driving it was huge yeah it's
amazing too because you guys had to make
those sacrifices and now you get to
experience the reward of it not just
financially but even just oh my gosh we
were a team we didn't see each other a
lot when we were working those jobs and
now it's like we get time together and
you can take your foot off the gas a
little bit and enjoy the fruit of your
hard work i think it's so interesting
when people sacrifice so much they
appreciate it that much more because you
work so hard to get there yeah so
absolutely who were the biggest
cheerleaders in your life during this
time
like our parents yeah
yeah
our friends didn't really understand
they're like why can't you hang out
i thought you're crazy
yes
oh that's amazing you guys well you've
done an absolute incredible incredible
job so how does it feel how does it feel
standing there without any payments
surreal i remember sitting in my car at
like lunch breaks and listening to the
show and being like so frustrated
because i'm like we're never gonna get
here it's taking forever like we only
have like 50 extra dollars this month or
whatever and so it's so swirl being here
and
being able to be where we are now and
not have that weight or anything yeah
it's freedom it is and and the beautiful
thing that i love that you just said is
i'm like there is hope that it is
possible because people are right now
are sitting in their cars thinking the
exact same thing
and you just gave them that green light
to say no even though it's it's an up
and down journey right it's not this
like straight up there's good days
there's bad days but as you continue to
be consistent in it and you get the
reward and you guys did it
congratulations
so so excited for you well we're going
to give you a copy of the legacy journey
because that is your next step and the
total money makeover so you can give to
someone to pass on but i'm so excited
for you guys nick and ashley from carson
city paid off 36 000
in 10 months making 48 to 104
thousand dollars let's hear a big debt
free scream three two one we're dead
i love it i love it i i love their story
because i'm like this is textbook like
this is exactly it and i talk to so many
women who are like i can't awesome i
can't you know i can get my husband on
board he's the free spirit you know and
then you're feeling this tension you
feel like it's not gonna happen and then
you're working it and it's like oh some
weeks you know or some months we only
had fifty dollars and it feels like it
never we're never gonna get there and
and they did i just love ashley's
persistence too because there's a lot of
people listening right now and the
spouse listening to the show is thinking
i want so bad for my my spouse to get on
board whether it's the the husband or
wife or whatever i want so bad for my
spouse to get on board but i just love
ashley's persistence and it paid off
like it you know your spouse better than
anybody you know the best way to go
about it how to have conversations how
to to connect there on things that you
guys disagree on and this is one of
those things that it's worth it to be
persistent it's worth it to keep on
talking until you can guys guys can get
on the same page because you're not
going to make progress until you're on
the same page and i love that they got
there and uh and now they have this to
show for it yeah and and and i feel like
consistently two people's income goes up
usually when we do this call they say
well we started here but we ended here
with a big jump because something does
unleash when you have a goal that you're
working towards something as big as
being debt-free you're looking at every
avenue right you're you're picking up
you're saying i can work extra i can do
what i can and it just shows the beauty
of like yeah when you put your mind
something it can happen that's right i
love it so great well again
congratulations nick and ashley for
being debt-free so glad that they're
here with us
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsey
show i'm rachel cruz hosting with
christy wright and we are here to answer
your questions
all right we're going to go over to ian
in baltimore hey ian welcome to the show
hey rachel i'm kirsty aloha um so i have
a huge um dilemma to face um my wife and
i we're currently on baby step 3b
we have our 360 emergency fund
and we have two kids under three our
huge dilemma is should we travel nurse
as a family
to either guam or move back home to
where i'm from in hawaii
and that's just part a because part b is
is it is it even worth it financially to
do it right now with the times with you
know travel nursing being um a hot
commodity
is it financially smart for us to move
as a family so
this is such a small question ian i mean
this is just a tiny little question make
the decision
no big deal
nothing really on the line here i don't
know okay so ian how much extra would
you guys make because you would do this
strictly out of a financial reason not
because you just like long to travel be
be you know travel as a nurse with your
family
well my so my wife is the nurse actually
um
so i mean you know we have our we have
we have enough money to where we can
use our use it up but we we want to buy
a house but same time we don't know
where we're going to end up because
we've been living a nomadic lifestyle
moving from utah to texas now we're in
maryland but we we kind of have that
itch to move again
um and we don't know where to settle and
but we want to travel right now where
the kids are still young they're not in
school
and we want to live the life you know
like kind of like what you're doing
disneyland on random weekends yeah so
um but we we want to have that kind of
lifestyle as a for for our kids um but
at the same time we want to you know
eventually settle down but
travel nursing has always been on top of
my wife's list and i want to make it
possible for her but i don't know
financially for us we're kind of country
to numbers is it it's costly it's going
to cost us like 6 grand you fly to guam
and then
you know we've talked to several
nursing agencies um but it's just
i don't know i mean
i don't know what to do
i'm curious about the choices here did
you say guam or hawaii where someone's
family is
yeah i'm from hawaii okay so you'd be
settled if you went to hawaii you'd
probably be there for like like that's
kind of like planting roots we're gonna
plant roots in hawaii probably
um i don't know that's the thing we i
moved to hawaii because i want i moved
out of hawaii to you know have a better
lifestyle i guess for more opportunities
i mean i can't see my kids being raised
there
um so why would you go to hawaii
um
because we want to be customers parents
and
my wife has never lived there she's only
visited it but she's never lived there
like i have man she wants my kids to
have that experience yeah yeah yeah
that's right like that nomadic lifestyle
i don't know
any other word i just don't know what to
do because we don't want to settle but
we want to travel and so i don't know
what and can you give us some like what
would you do in your situation if you
guys were have two kids under three you
you had like an opportunity to travel
you have nothing no tie
yeah and ann can i tell you can i tell
you what i would do with with two young
kids in terms of traveling traveling is
the last thing i would want to do with
two children so i'm having trouble
relating because travel for me is zero
fun with small children like that's the
most stressful activity i do with my
kids so i can't even sort of relate but
here's the good news for you that i will
speak to you call it asking if it's a
financial
decision and because y'all are debt-free
and because you're on baby step 3b and
you're in a good position you actually
don't have to make this decision based
on money you're not asking about some
massive expense because you'd be making
more money so i know this is not maybe
what you wanted to hear but you can kind
of do what you want to which is why we
tell people to get debt free in the
first place is so that you can do what
you want to so if you're the kind of
people that travel excites you in a new
place like guam i don't know what's
going on in guam i don't know let's go
move there and find out with our two
small kids if that is fun for you i find
that crazy ian but i think you should do
it i think you should do what you want
to do because you've earned the spot
financially to be able to do what you
want to do even if i don't get it if
somebody else doesn't get it it's your
life your kids your family your money
and you can and that's the coolest place
to be so i think i think if you want to
go you go go to guam and go
amen sister christy i i will i'm like
not no longer like i cannot relate and i
would never want to drink my
two-year-old with grandparents so we
don't have to be on a plane with them so
christie or we don't get it but no but
for real ian christie's exactly right
it's what you guys want i mean
literally my i we had friends they sold
their house put all their stuff in a
storage unit because they had no debt
they saved up a ton of money over three
years and their goal was to travel for
six months around the world with their
kids yeah and they did it and they paid
cash and they did it and that's what you
can do it's what you guys want so
um yes understand and know that
each of these scenarios the hawaii or
the traveling nurse maybe not to go on
but somewhere else it's always going to
be available so if you guys choose one
and say hey we're going to move to
hawaii for a little bit i would not buy
a home in hawaii if you're not going to
be there more than five years just
that's a little financial advice i'm
gonna give you um but yeah maybe you go
rent there for a year and your wife's
like perfect i got the experience right
now i'm done and then maybe you say all
right we're gonna go back to the
the big land of
north america i guess hawaii's in north
america go back
and you know be have a more predictable
lifestyle in a sense that we're gonna
buy a home and settle down or maybe you
leave hawaii and you say we wanna go
travel and be a nurse and now you can
like these options aren't there's not
gonna be closed doors i don't think for
you guys
um
coming up does that help ian at all us
just kind of talking through it
uh yes it does um
it's just like you know like the living
situation i we know like the market is
so volatile right now
um and it's just uh i guess financially
we're thinking like
is it is it worth it to you know pay for
our flights here and there to to live
for that you know contract that she you
know what if it's six to eight to 13
weeks um i'm not sure if you guys are
from like travel nursing but like you
know it's very it's unpredictable
uh nothing is guaranteed there so you
could have a contract that
you know
it'll expire and then oh you need to go
find another one so you'll have to move
you know so just
right but you make more right you make
quite a bit more
okay so here's the thing i just want to
remind you you're not considering going
to guam for nursing you can nurse right
where you can have nursing the nursing
job right where you are you're going for
the experience one of the things you
said on this call that i think is so
important to pay attention to is we have
the itch rachel and i don't have that
itch we don't know that itch that you're
talking about but if you have it that's
why you're going you're going for the
experience
of experiencing nursing somewhere else
yes you're going to make a good income
that will offset the cost to get there
but you're not going because it's a
financial move if you think of it as a
financial move then it doesn't
necessarily make sense you're going
because you want to have the experience
of going somewhere you've never been and
that's oh you're perfectly able to do
that and that's totally fine i think it
just comes down to you figuring out what
this looks like for you in your life and
it's okay if it looks different than
someone else it's okay if it doesn't
look like your neighbors or what your
parents did that's what's really cool
about the world we live in you have put
yourself in a position financially to
look at that and say where do we want to
work where do we want to live and maybe
we're going to be nomads forever and
that's cool you can do that yep
absolutely and i think that that is
um
the key part that i want people to hear
about this is that they are in a place
that they have no debt
they have a fully funded emergency fund
and they're saving up
babysit 3b which is for a down payment
on a home and again ian i would not
purchase a home unless you're going to
be somewhere for five years or longer so
just keep that savings going if you want
but don't feel the pressure to put that
down for a down payment on a house
you're only going to be somewhere for a
year or two
but they but they have these choices
they have the freedom
with options and choices of what they
want to do and that's the power of this
you guys when you are intentional with
your money and you don't owe anyone
anything and you have a safety net of a
savings account like you get to make
these decisions yeah maybe our parents
generation thinks that we're crazy and
you know but but i'm like you can you
can go travel you can go live in hawaii
for a year or two
rent and why not i mean if that's what
you're choosing to do and that's what
that's what's fun for you guys and as a
family that's something you guys value
there's nothing immoral about that you
can you can live that out well that's
what that's what everything that we
teach is about it's not about the money
it's about the options it gives you when
you have money you have power when you
have money if you control when you have
money you have options you can move or
you want to move cover expenses you want
to cover do what's right for you and so
that is the purpose it's it's it allows
you that and and you've got that ian
you've done great absolutely absolutely
well as we close out this hour i want to
thank producer ben hill and associate
producer kelly daniel
and you chrissy for being on with me and
you america for listening this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i am rachel cruz best-selling
author and ramsey personality sitting
beside me today on the show is christy
wright best-selling author ramsey
personality host of the christy wright
show
and real life friend yeah
we're taking your calls working together
and getting to have a little fun in the
process that's right so you can give us
a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five all right we have a
jeremiah in roanoke hey jeremiah welcome
to the show
good afternoon rachel christie thanks
for taking my call absolutely how can we
help
well i wanted to jump right into my
question before i give a 10 second plug
thank you for everything you guys do in
educating the nation on the student bone
crisis and the alternates by god's grace
i am actually in the dissertation phase
of a doctorate and have been able to
make it the entire way through without a
penny of debt so it is happening i
appreciate wow
can i ask you a question jeremy how are
you how did you do that because people
think that's impossible
it it you'd think it was impossible but
no it's not uh it was a combination of
there were some scholarships early on an
undergraduate
for my graduate degree for a master's i
found out that the school that my wife
wanted to
get a bachelor's in nursing in if i had
a job any job there she got preschool
and i got preschool so i worked security
for
the time i was there and we got
preschool that way and the rest have
been cash flowing amazing jeremiah
well done well well done
all right thanks for letting me
interview you for a second what's your
question for us
all right so my wife and i we are
currently on baby steps four through six
uh we have a home right now but we're
starting to outgrow it
so we paused and went back to 3b and
have been just stocking uh socking it
away
saving up for a down payment from a
building standpoint
uh right now we we have about 125 000 in
equity on our existing home
we've got about 40 000 above our
emergency fund that is saved for the
home we want to build looking to have
about 100 cash on hand for the for the
down payment for the build it's going to
take us probably another 12 to 18 months
to get there i'm getting a little
anxious uh pausing this long i'm four
five and six i feel like it's a wise
plan but i guess i just wanted to run
the numbers but you make sure you all
thought that was a good plan jeremiah
how old are you
i am 37. you're 37.
and so your question is pausing four
five and six to continue to build on
this baby step 3b is going to take you
guys another probably what six months
did you say six months a year
about 12 to 18 months
beyond where we're at right now and it
and that will be
10 to 20 for your down payment for the
build
or is that better twenty percent that
would be twenty percent for the build
and then once the build is completed and
we sell our existing home uh we would
have uh lord willing uh somewhere over a
hundred thousand of equity that we would
apply towards the principal on the on
the new build okay
well jeremiah i'll i'll say this i
you're fine i understand that 12 months
of pausing retirement um
is kind of freaky and you're like oh
gosh but you're going to
be able to make up for that
so fast not just with your age but the
fact that you guys already are going to
have so much equity going into this home
you're going to get to baby steps four
five and six really quickly uh maybe
even baby step six you may be able to
pay off this house even even the new
build you know with you know i didn't
even ask the numbers but um faster for
sure than that 15-year mortgage and
that's going to give you more cash to go
and invest other places not just
retirement i mean you guys can open up
mutual funds you can invest in real
estate
you guys are going to be you're going to
be totally fine i mean if you're
65 with no savings no retirement this is
a different conversation but you guys
are in a great spot and i understand the
feeling of still pausing retirement
feels like oh but as much cash as you
can put towards and get hit that 20 you
can avoid pmi i mean there's there's a
lot of pros here uh in the short term
and in the long term you're just not
gonna be that affected by it
mathematically yeah and it's just it
comes down to what's right for you at
the right time this is right for you
right now you've decided this is a
priority and so it's just a temporary
redirection of your funds and your focus
and then you're going to get right back
on track
all right coming up next is forest in
west virginia hey forest welcome to the
show
hello
oh how can we help
yeah so i have a question about um it's
about a debt situation um
so me and my wife we
i brought in about fifty eight thousand
dollars with student loan debt and uh
marriage and she brought in about
sixteen thousand
and i just got a job as a teacher and
and she's an engineer so it was looking
pretty good as far as paying off the
debt but she's wanting to stay home with
our with our son now so i was wanting to
know
is there any way that we can really make
this possible anytime soon or this is
something we're gonna have to
power through
how much are you guys making a year
together and then how much would you
make if she stopped working
about a hundred grand
um
but
together we are okay
but
we stopped working it'd be about 35 000
about about 49 000 because i'm a youth
pastor too and they pay me a stipend but
okay um
but uh that'd be about how much we make
yep okay um
well again we we took a call like this
in the last hour and for us this is this
is one of these questions that it's it's
kind of a value system conversation to
have and
we talk to a lot of people on the
debt-free stage and they say you know
the things we wanted in life we paused
including staying at home because we
wanted this debt knocked out and the
fastest way we could do that was with
you know two incomes coming in and just
knocking it out really quickly and then
and then having no debt you have so much
so many options
beyond that some people say no this is
something that i feel called to like i'm
i'm going to be home and figure out
maybe a way to earn some extra money
while home and it's going to take us a
longer debt-free process but we just
know
the deeper you sacrifice lifestyle the
more income you're bringing in the
faster obviously mathematically you're
going to be getting out of debt what's
the age of your do you have one child or
how many kids you have
i have one he's 15 months old 15 months
okay yeah i i agree and i know that some
of the things that go into that decision
are the ages of kids because some people
think oh well when my kids are in school
like i don't mind going back to work at
all i just want to be home in these you
know young years and these are all
things you guys should talk about so
it's it's kind of a
more extreme example of where someone
says oh should i cut out you know all
television all cable all everything to
get out of debt or am i going to keep my
cell phone and maybe it takes me a
little bit longer so there's a there's a
range in there of how gazelle intense
you guys want to get and what other
things that affect like like how old
your son is and whether or not you want
to be home you will get a debt faster
obviously with two incomes the thing
that i like to do for us and this is
something that you guys can have this
conversation
is i don't like two bad options like oh
i'm gonna work full time and not feel
like i don't get to see my kids or i'm
going to be in debt forever what is is
there a third or fourth or fifth option
where she's working from home or
starting a side business or doing a
virtual assistant where maybe there's a
happy medium and you just look at other
options to consider as you as you plan
your next step that's great yep looking
at all different options yeah it doesn't
have to be a or b right there's other
things out there for sure it's a great
question for us thanks for calling in
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i am
rachel cruz and with me hosting today
christy wright and we are taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
all right up next from canada ontario
gazette is with us hey welcome to the
show
hey guys uh rachel christie thanks for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help
uh so my wife and i finally got married
back in september
and we are expecting a child in february
yeah congratulations amazing thank you
thank you very much and so
right now we've been saving up some uh
we have some money and savings and we're
driving a houthi we just have one car
um and i kind of feel like it's coming
to the end of its life i got it it has a
couple problems uh you know check engine
light 300 000 kilometers um
i've got it checked out they weren't 100
able to tell me what was wrong with it
so i'm going to get a second check done
on it but
essentially you know i'm just wondering
when would be a good time to
up you know move up in vehicle we have
about 12 000 saved up right now
but since we got married i also took on
some of her debt so went from baby step
three back to two
and uh
we have about 35 000 in student loans
that there and that's about it
um
so when it comes to the car
situation and considering where you guys
are in the baby steps i mean obviously
you're gonna be paying cash for the next
car
um and the baby comes in february you
said you guys yeah um
so what
what do you think you could sell it for
have you kelly blue book did all the the
current car you have um
yeah i mean with the with the
you know
the kind of work that it needs no more
than like five or six hundred dollars
probably okay okay so it really is a
hooptie is what we say okay
it is a 2003 honda element nice okay hey
that's pretty good it's lasted lasted a
good bit yeah i like it i like it it has
it's just it has a really bad like
vibrating problem right now at like
highway speeds as well as a transmission
solenoid i think it was like it's got a
few problems well my rule of thumb
always again with cars is this is
something that gets you to point a to
point b and in this situation you want
something obviously reliable but it is
amazing to me how many five six
thousand dollar cars
are out there that are great cars that
that will last and are reliable and can
get you through this so so i don't want
you
when you do replace the car um
obviously to buy anything
crazy expensive this again needs to get
you to point a to point b
um
and so it's you're not gonna be spending
a ton and i would take that 12 grand i
mean maybe take 5 000 of it go buy honda
civic i always use honda i don't know
why they go forever i do i know a honda
toyota or something something that just
goes i like the hondas yeah the hondas
are pretty good toyotas they just they
have longevity i was looking at a crv at
around hopefully i don't know five grand
was a bit too much but they seemed like
whenever i seem to find one it just
seems to sell like right away so
is it something i should maybe pull the
trigger on if i see a good deal on or
just wait i was hoping to get into a new
car by the time the baby comes around
yeah i mean i would say at this point i
mean if your car's worth 500 and you
still have to do maintenance on all of
it i mean it's inevitable you're gonna
have to get a new car soon so yeah so
yeah if there is something and again you
guys talk it out see what you're
comfortable with and then i i really
want you guys to lay out the rest of
this money because
um because you're gonna be able to knock
out some of this thirty five thousand
dollars with your savings keeping that
thousand dollar savings account but i i
want you guys still focused on getting
this out i know you know you're you're
in a fun new season you're newly married
baby on the way all of it but getting
this 35 000 that needs to be the biggest
priority and so the club
yeah we're on a budget uh you know we
have both read um it is dave ramsey's
complete guide to money
um which you know people found super
helpful my boss gifted it to me so we're
on a monthly budget um i guess the size
question is when would be a good time to
sort of i know
you guys say you know to pause
when we're expecting uh or just
emergencies in general so when would be
a good time to sort of take what we have
saved up and just start tackling the
debt again
um that's a great point i totally forgot
about that i'm obviously in the third
hour the show yes yeah you guys don't
need to be that's right you need to be
yes saving you're doing exactly right
and when the baby comes you guys are
home from the hospital mom's good baby's
good that's when you go and take the
rest of that cash yes and pay it off
you're exactly right pausing baby step
two while you're expecting um is what we
recommend so i would i would continue to
do that yeah and you're gonna get a
position to take about half of that get
you a better car that's going to give
you peace of mind when the baby's here
and then keep saving between now and
then and then take that and put
everything other than a thousand dollars
at that debt and you'll just keep
tracking that's right great job all
right up next we have tony in fort
lauderdale hey tony welcome to the show
hey can you hear me yes we can what's
going on
hey well it's really cool to be talking
to both of you i really like the podcast
um
and thanks for taking my call thank you
um
to be brief i
i would say that i started this whole
money makeover like two years ago i've
been trying to do the dave ramsey plan
and um you know continue on that route
but
you know obviously i've made mistakes
down the road but in the last couple
months um you know me and my girlfriend
that we had been dating and living
together for six years
she decided to kind of leave break up
whatever you want to call it so we're
going through a transition right now
so my two questions are um i don't know
if you guys have any great advice or
like any best places to recommend
selling an engagement ring
um so i bought one for like 5400 like in
2019 i just haven't presented it just
because you know i just never really saw
an opportunity and then this came up
obviously yeah um and then the second
question is like going through a
transition like you know leaving your
current home and then um you know
starting a new rent by yourself is that
a time to like stop the baby steps
temporarily and like put a little bit
more into savings to try to like
re-um
you know discover your new bills
well how are you doing tony i mean you
you broke up with a long-term
girlfriend that you had a ring for for a
few years
yeah no i mean it's definitely really
sad um
but luckily you know i've got a good
group of friends and stuff and you know
i don't necessarily know if there's like
you know
something on her end that she's not
telling me like mental health or drugs
that has to do with why she's reporting
but like you know so it's not like i've
got like any great answer for why we
broke up um but like you know mentally
i'm
you know i've read a codependent no more
and you know so i'm trying to just uh
stay positive yep
i'm sorry you're going through that yeah
that's that's hard um as far as selling
the ring
somewhere specific
there's there are you know used
yeah jewelry stores i mean there are
places that do that i don't know if i
know somewhere specific in fort
lauderdale i don't know if you know no i
think you just do
a little bit of research i mean it's
just going to take some asking around
going you could literally go to jewelry
stores
um i mean you could sell it yourself
like you know like we say private party
with a car
yourself
um you could do that on craigslist
facebook marketplace i mean if you
do you have debt
yes um yeah i do i have uh i can list it
out if you guys want just how much total
uh total is
twelve
twelve hundred twelve thousand seven
hundred on a personal loan
ninety four hundred on a car and then
another four thousand on ammo okay that
cree the reason i asked is because that
creates a little bit more urgency if you
didn't have debt i'd be like well you
can kind of hang on to this ring until
you really find a good price for it that
you feel good about selling it for um
it's a little bit more urgent with this
debt because you could take the money
that you're going to get from it and put
it on that debt but yeah i think i think
as far as selling it where to sell it
you literally treat it like as if we
were you're going to make a big purchase
and you're going to ask around who can
you get the most you know where can you
get the most money for it do a little
bit of digging whether that's um you
know private party through facebook
marketplace craigslist whatever if
there's a jewelry site like a
consignment jewelry site
um and asking some jewelry stores just
asking around a little bit i think we'll
tell you how to go about that one yeah
and then
i would not stop the baby steps tony i
mean at this point i would still
continue on don't go purchase a home if
you're moving out of your place
rent for a little bit and start working
on tackling this debt but with money
from that ring and everything
should help you in it so i'm sorry tony
you're going through that but i
appreciate appreciate your call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
welcome back america i am rachel cruz
and with me co-hosting today is christy
wright
and we have some fun things kind of
going on here at ramsey solutions and um
and and some stuff because it's been a
hard a hard 18 months 24 months yeah for
a lot of people well and the whole heart
behind this show is to help you guys get
control of your money and the good news
is this show is a great way for you to
have that ongoing inspiration and
encouragement hear the stories of people
hear the advice that maybe you have a
similar question but the reality is we
also have a lot of tools that help you
put this into practice and i know that
the last year and a half has been really
hard i know a lot of you have
experienced a ton of stress a ton of
worry a ton of wondering what's going to
happen next and man the unknown is just
so overwhelming it's just the fear of
not knowing what's gonna happen you've
probably felt that with your money you
felt tired stuck stretched too thin
we've all been there
but it doesn't have to be that way you
just need a plan because a plan gives
you the confidence that you need even
when everything else seems out of
control and that plan that we have
created that is proven
that we have used to teach people to get
out of debt and build wealth
is called financial peace university
this class will teach you everything you
need to know to save money pay off debt
and build wealth for the future you can
stream the lessons on your own or you
can get support by going through the
class with other people then here's what
you'll do you'll put that plan into
action with the premium version of our
every dollar budgeting app it actually
syncs your bank to your budget and you
can easily track your spending and see
where your money goes you get all this
with a ramsey plus membership this is
why we talk about ramsay plus it is our
class that teaches you what to do with
your money and our budgeting tool that
helps you put it into practice and live
this out every single day
you don't have to stay exhausted and
overwhelmed you can win with money to
start your free trial of ramsey plus
text trial to 33789
that's trial two three three seven eight
nine give it a try for free practice
this budgeting thing watch some of the
lessons and watch how you instantly
reduce the stress
you reduce the overwhelm because you
have a plan you have the tools and you
know what you need to do to get control
of your money that's trial to 33789
trial to 33789 to start your free trial
of ramsey plus take the class and get
the budgeting app yep and a lot of
people that that call in to do their
debt free screen they there's something
that has helped them listening to the
show helps a lot of them say financial
peace university and getting more
content and more knowledge on how to
apply it
talking with friends and having
community around you i mean there's so
many aspects to this journey and ramsay
plus gives you so many of those tools
right there so it is it's such a it's
such a helpful thing and again financial
peace university it's it's our flagship
program that
has helped literally millions of people
get educated like this is it's all it's
mind-boggling to me i've done this you
know i've been in this for 12 years now
but still i'm like you can graduate from
college and you don't have a club you
you haven't been you haven't gone
through a class necessarily on the
basics of budgeting and insurance and
emergency funds and the difference
between money market accounts and mutual
funds like the the basics of personal
finance
the class that you need it is financial
peace university you don't always get it
in an educational setting even though we
have foundations and personal finance
our curriculum in high schools all over
america but man this is like the class
that everyone needs
and the reason we put everything that we
do into plan format
is because when you can see it you can
do it so we don't just give you a bunch
of scattered information a bunch of um
disconnected pieces of the puzzle we
actually show you step by step and you
will find that in any book that we write
any book that we publish any product
that we create any course that we create
it's in a plan format it is going to be
a step-by-step plan so that you know
what steps to take because truly when
you can see it you can do it
all right up next is bob in west palm
beach florida hey bob welcome to the
show
hey christy rachel how are you doing
we're doing great how can we help
yeah so i have one question my question
for you today is
um i graduated as an engineer this past
summer
and i am extremely passionate about
fishing so i've developed an idea for a
fishing backpack
i want to try to manufacture but it's
pretty expensive the whole process of um
manufacturing you know you need to order
a certain minimum of units so i project
more or less it would be um
around 10 to 15 000 which
seems a lot to me so i'm pretty hesitant
on it
because i like at the end of the day i
just don't know if it'll do well in the
market
okay
you're cutting out a little bit bob
what are you manufacturing i'd miss the
actual thing you're manufacturing
yeah a fishing backpack a fishing
backpack
yeah okay so when you sorry i've got
some follow-up here really quickly when
you talk about there's a minimum order
typically there's a minimum order for a
price break but you could order small
batch orders it's just gonna be much
more expensive per unit is that the case
in your situation or you're saying they
will not manufacture it for less than
whatever this this minimum is you're
saying
yeah because it's a unique design they
don't want to go through trouble i guess
to manufacture a small amount they said
that the minimum for them would be 500
and i've contacted a few others and more
or less that is the minimum amount
okay do you have any past experience bob
was selling this type of backpack like
do you do you have any track record of
it
no past experience whatsoever
yeah do you have anyone to sell it to
bob do you have an audience do you have
a blog do you have a fishing community
that you hang out with that you have uh
qualified people that would want this
backpack
i do not all right
these are some red flags for me bob
if you had an audience like let's say
that you had a podcast you had a blog
you had a fishing community you teach
phishing classes some people that would
be interested in this product then i
would say you could
you could put the money into it if you
have it okay we're only going to cash
flow this i don't want you to take out
any debt but you could even do it on
pre-order like you could pre-sell these
take the payment
and then use some of that cash to fund
it let's say that you pre-sell them you
know for two months and you at least get
a a good chunk of cash and those release
you know on whatever date you you deem
that they're going to release the fact
that you don't have anyone to sell it to
is the biggest concern to me because it
doesn't matter if you create the best
product in the world if you don't have
an audience or write the best book in
the world if you don't have audience
then no one's going to buy it and so
what i would encourage you to do that is
more concerning to me than just the
money i would encourage you to work on
the marketing of it to work on building
the audience creating the demand around
it getting yourself in these
spaces um to generate interest and maybe
maybe for you it looks like you're going
to create um
uh you know
an ebook a download something to start
building an email list of people that
are interested in fishing that are
interested in this thing that you're
going to create a product around but you
just start to generate some demand and
brand yourself as an expert in the space
or a
person that provides content and
solutions in this space then maybe in a
year maybe in a year i'm not saying you
can't do it but right now you're going
to have 500 backpacks on your hand and
it's not because the idea is not awesome
it's just because you don't have people
to sell it to you um
if you'll stay on the line bob i would
love to have kelly send you a copy of my
book business boutique i know it says a
woman's guide for making money doing
what she loves but the business
principles are proven whether you're a
male or female it doesn't really matter
but i talk about getting your market i
talk about marketing and building your
market building the demand for this
thing and so that would be a great
resource for you to start to think about
how you're going to
get into the spaces where the people are
that would want this thing and then go
create it when you have people to sell
it to if you've got the cash i think
that you can sell 500 of these i just
think you need the people there in order
to be able to do that bob i'm just
curious what do you do for a living how
did you get into
creating and inventing this fishing
backpack
yeah so i i'm an engineer by trade so
it's very natural for me to just create
stuff again and a follow-up question um
well when you're doing like when you're
making a company like this and yourself
financing this is there a percentage of
your net worth that
would be considered too risky to
put into it for example i have 60 000
saved up over
my lifetime so
would it be feasible or would it be too
risky for me to put five thousand ten
thousand into this company or any other
company that i might want
no you can that's not too risky you just
need a proven business plan that you're
gonna be able to make it back because
just because you have it it's easy to
lose it because you're like oh i've got
it i still want your business plans
showing that you can make that back
check out one more thing bob i've never
used it but i've heard of people that
have startup labs
startuplabs.com it's where you can start
to generate interest around your idea
try that i've heard someone else use
that i don't know anything about it but
that could be another resource for you
that's great this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
the lord himself goes before you and
will be with you he will never leave you
nor forsake you do not be afraid do not
be discouraged
deuteronomy 31 8. it's never too late to
be what you might have been
george eliot
rachel you got some exciting news you
have a new color of your walls
so fun
so the rachel cruz wallet has
um it's been a fun project for me to to
to do and to finally have people
actually buy and use because it's a year
have you had it out a year yeah over
and it is it's it's everything we talk
about when it comes to because i love
talking about budgeting i love talking
about how
um living this plan doesn't mean you
can't enjoy life or have a great life
that was always kind of my
assumption i feel like as a free spirit
as a spender i'd hear the word budget
and it was like oh well that means you
can't go shopping you can't go on
vacation you can't have any fun and i
was like god people on budgets are
terrible people like that is not a fun
life
but really truly
living this out especially after once i
got married and
realizing no a budget really does give
you this freedom it gives you this peace
of mind because you have a plan you know
what's going on never once are you
okay i went to target today here's a
great example and our our neighborhood
we'll do these like little boob baskets
i don't know if y'all haven't you've
been booed have you heard of this no you
so you like do a basket with just some
treats and stuff and you like don't know
who it's from but you go to your front
door and there's a little basket it says
you've been boots then you've got to go
is this for halloween or just for house
no for help yeah yeah yeah around
halloween so guys i go to target and i
was like okay and i looked in our little
miscellaneous category on every dollar
and i was like perfect i know how much
we have left i mean like i spent all
that on this little blue basket but i'm
like i can go
down the target aisle you know and just
have the girls pick out some stuff and
i'm like that's great i'm not sitting
there being like
this is a waste of money is this so good
you know and you're second guessing
everything you can enjoy life right but
you have a plan and so the wallet has a
built-in envelope system because when
you're starting budgeting if you if you
are early on in this process
we recommend cashing out a few
categories just to have cash because you
end up not only spending less when you
spend with cash studies have proven that
but also it's just this built-in
accountability you know how much you
have in each category and it just gives
you this extra sense of control
well people use paper envelopes and all
that which is fine but i was like this
can be cute this could be beautiful and
we can have a really great wallet and us
ladies out there who have a lot of stuff
and so i created the wallet the rachel
cruz wallet and so there's
holder you know there's tons of card
holders for memberships or debit cards
you have and then and then these slots
for
your cash and so we came out with a
black and camel version that have
colors that have sold tremendously well
and then came out with a metallic blush
for just a limited time that sold out in
like
i think two weeks 14 days and so we have
launched this week the third
uh color that will be where you can
consistently buy it's not for a limited
time uh but it's the classic brown yeah
so that is out and yeah perfect
christmas gift and and that's what's fun
because we were just talking about this
earlier but there's all kinds of
shipping weirdness going on in the
country and um yeah you can get your
christmas gifts early i've i've done
most of my christmas shopping already
because i was so scared of the shipping
issues and so i just even just a couple
days ago hit it and all the spots in the
you know the kids can't find um but if
you want to get this as a gift for
someone someone that is a huge fan
someone that's on the ramsay plan um
this is a great gift it's it's in the
box the presentation is beautiful um but
that's true for anything um in our store
at rmc solutions.com if you want to get
some of the book if you want to get um
uh the goal planner my 2022 goal planner
is out if you want to get them ken's new
book all of these things are available
to you in the ramsey solutions store and
i would just encourage you to shop early
especially for things that could sell
out my goal planner sells out every year
um you know i don't know what the
inventory is like on the wallet but go
ahead and get it and you don't worry
about shipping you don't have to worry
about stressing out about that and
you've got it for christmas it's a great
gift and it's a good reminder it's 10
weeks to christmas you guys crazy is
that not nice it's almost the end of
october so pl plan this you guys look at
christmas is always the holiday that
people we overspend people go into deep
debt for and it is because we're not
planning so we're giving you lots of
heads up lots of heads up uh on being
able to plan for things um especially
around the holidays and yes i turned on
the news too and all the
shipping cargo that's just sitting there
i'm like oh god i got stressed just
seeing the picture i was like oh my gosh
so it's crazy all right up next is josh
from indianapolis hey josh welcome to
the show
hi i'm so excited to talk to you too
absolutely how can we help
well i'm getting married this weekend
congratulations wow
yay thanks and
we are also moving um in two months um
so
we we are unsure of what um
our emergency fund should look like or
what our moving costs uh we kind of we
have a mover already kind of established
but we won't be employed uh when we get
where we're going um so
we're we're just kind of i'm i'm
i like to i don't know i don't know
where we should be okay what's the story
i feel like there's more to this story
you're getting married
why are you moving what what where where
are you moving to my we're actually
moving from um new york to indianapolis
um
and um
yeah so we have a fully funded emergency
fund we don't have any debt we're
we're investing awesome
but some of that a lot of that makes me
nervous um
because we won't
we don't have jobs yet um but
you know we both have skill sets that i
think will
will get jobs quickly
what's in indianapolis josh just curious
family
yes family okay cool and if you're in
new york it's probably
a lesser uh
expenses when it comes to the living
yeah yeah and it's politically
oppressive
yeah fair and there's a great uh this is
a great time to get it i mean
everybody's hiring so you're yeah i'm
not worried about you being able to get
a job when you get there and it sounds
like you'll have put yourself in a
really great position financially
already yeah be a debt-free and
emergency fund i would say just be just
be aware of it i mean even even though i
know you guys have the movers it's in
two months so maybe if you haven't
already maybe you did price out
a couple of movers and just be aware and
and i would not at this point buy
anything right now in indianapolis not
because of the market or anything just
because of you guys are newly married
you're going to a new city you've just
coming off of living in new york and
it's like okay just take a breather um
but this emerges
yeah she's never lived in indianapolis
so i think that's that's what our plan
was as well just kind of get a sense for
the neighborhoods but i should also
mention i'm going to grad school
starting in january too but it's it's
flexible it's online and
but i'll be working i'll be trying to
trying to work full-time so yeah that
kind of it also it just adds to the
concern like
being married moving and a new lifestyle
or of going back to studying and
workings too so it's yeah it's a lot and
it seems like you're aware of it you
know and and
you'll plan for that the other thing i
would say is you can start looking for
jobs now i think if you have if you had
a job lined up by the time you got there
in the next couple months that would
give you peace of mind you're not
starting from scratch when you get there
start looking now and it's very normal
to do zoom interviews or they may fly
you in for further interviews we do that
here as a company when we're recruiting
people or talking to people from out of
state so you don't have to wait till you
get there to start looking that may
relieve some of your stress of feeling
like oh my gosh i'm moving and this and
this and this if you had a job lined up
or your wife did that could just help
alleviate that but it sounds like you
know what you're in for i would just
just like rachel said reduce stress in
the areas that you can so not buying a
house will reduce stress
trying to line up a job starting now
will reduce the stress there are there
are some variables in this that you can
control to just not eliminate it but
reduce the stress of the whole situation
yeah how old are you guys josh i'm just
curious
31 and 32. okay have you guys been
married before
no no okay because also getting married
later in life i mean both have pros and
cons right there's pros and cons getting
married young and later but you guys do
have two established lives that you're
going to be coming in and kind of
merging and again pros and cons to that
but um but i think that there's some
some great there's there's a level of
stability there because you guys kind of
know who you are you know even on a
logistical level
the careers you have your passions where
you're going all of that so i think
that's that gives you some kind of
foundation there for sure yeah you're
right because there's a there's a hard
part of getting married later because
you're you're kind of established yeah
yeah exactly i mean there's a lot
there's a hey i have my life and when
you're 21 you're like i don't know we'll
just figure it out together right that's
right yeah that's right that's all of it
it's all of it but the emergency fund
josh that's why that's why we teach that
is for moments like this even though i
know it's not a quote-unquote emergency
but you have savings there lined up if
you need it well christy this was fun
today that's great i love it love
hanging out with you and thank you guys
out there for calling in and listening
in uh hopefully this show helped you i
want to thank producer ben hill and
associate producer kelly daniel
and again you america thank you so much
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you